[Music]
a king a Creator and real life dad to an
MCU director while these Marvel actors
are no longer with us their performances
will live on in the superhero cinematic
Wilderness of the 1990s long before Toby
Maguire played Spider-Man or the launch
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe comic
fans hungry for Content had to make do
with Fair like Captain America a
lowbudget adaptation released directly
to home video and cable in 1992 little
known up andom Matt Salinger son of
acclaimed and inclusive author JD singer
played Steve Rogers and the best known
actor in the film was arguably Darren
McGavin who portrayed World War II Era
military authority figure General
Fleming I I want to live on a a clean
Planet just as much as the next fell you
just simply can't expect us to cut back
on our solid waste the familiar face
character actor had worked in mainstream
movies and television since the 1950s
when he starred in the shows Mickey
Spain's Mike Hammer and Riverboat in the
' 70s McGavin headlines the cult horror
Sci-Fi series cjack The nightstalker
just a few years before H Landa's most
famous role that of ralphy's father or
the old man in A Christmas Story he
played dads often including his role as
Billy Madison's father in Billy Madison
McGavin died in 2006 at the age of 83
leaving behind many roles that were far
more memorable than his part in Captain
America Chadwick Boseman had a promising
start in Hollywood prior to joining the
Marvel Cinematic Universe he first rosee
to prominence portraying baseball player
Jackie Robinson in the biopic 42 which
he followed up with performances as
other historical figures like James
Brown and th Good Marshall and their
respective biopics his biggest break
however came when he debuted in Captain
America Civil War as tala the young king
of wakanda who adopts the superhero
mantle of black panther my name is King
tala son of King
tachaka I Am The Sovereign ruler of the
nation of
boseman's starring role in 2018s Black
Panther made him an international
Superstar sadly his life was cut short
in its prime the actor died from colon
cancer in August 2020 his role in the
2020 August Wilson adaptation maren's
black bottom earned imposturous
nominations at the Screen Actors Guild
Awards the Golden Globes and the Academy
Awards in 2021 as for his role in the
Marvel Universe the decision was made to
not recast the actor in the role of tala
with black panther director Ryan cougler
instead incorporating the loss of the
character into the next film black
panther wakanda forever was released in
2022 paying tribute to boseman's
meaningful impact on the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and passing on the
mantle of black panther to his sister sh
played by Leticia Wright in my culture
death it's not the
end it's more a stepping off point many
fandoms were devastated when Annie
woring died in January 2023 the actor
was widely known for her roles in shows
like 24 and Timeless as well as
supporting roles in Castle The Vampire
Diaries and the rookie woring also
notably performed motion capture and
voice acting for the iconic 2013 video
game The Last of Us as Tess a Smuggler
who's partnered with Joel at the start
of the game you have to run you want us
to just leave you here yes there is no
way I will not turn into one of those
things woring also appears as part of
the main cast in Marvel's runaways a
Hulu series that premiered in 2017
running for a total of three seasons
woring portrayed Leslie Dean a religious
leader and mother to Virginia gardeners
karolina Dean more recently in 20122
woring also appeared in Star Trek pakan
as the Bor Queen a role originated by
Alice C in Star Trek first Contact sadly
this wound up being waring's final TV
role the actor was diagnosed with cancer
in in 2020 but kept her realness a
secret leading up to her death in 2023
her condition had even prevented her
from making a guest appearance in HBO's
TV adaptation of The Last of Us
alongside other actors from the games
Ray Stevenson was no stranger to the
Marvel Universe when he joined the cast
of 2011's Thor having previously
appeared as Frank Castle also known as
The Punisher in the 2018 film Punisher
war zone over the years Stenson was also
notable for appearances in films like
kill the Irishman and R as well as
television series like Dexter black saes
and Star Wars Rebels whatever's about to
happen there's no stopping it now
however in 2011 he made his Marvel
Cinematic Universe debut as volag and as
guardian Warrior who helps rescue Thor
from Earth after his banishment by Odin
Stevenson repris a role in Thor the Dark
World where volag fights alongside Thor
against the dark elves and Thor Ragnarok
where he's killed by Hela during her
conquest of Asgard at the beginning of
the film unfortunately Thor Ragnarok
ended up being Stevenson's last
appearance in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the actor died in May 20123
after a sudden hospitalization for
filming in Italy for fans of the actor's
work he made a postumus appearance in
the Disney plus Star Wars series Ahsoka
James kobby played two separate Marvel
characters on the big screen the first
was a police officer in 2014's The
Amazing Spider-Man 2 but he had a more
significant role than Jessica Jones albe
it only appearing in one episode of the
series his lack of presence in the show
is mainly due to the fact that he played
Jessica's Father Brian Jones who dies in
a car accident prior to the events of
the show flashbacks in the first season
episode depict Brian as arrogant and
insecure about his own masculinity and
these qualities eventually result in the
car accident that kills both him and
imbues his wife and daughter with
superpowers the incident continues to
haunt Jessica throughout the series
although Colby never reappears as the
character sadly Colby died in February
2018 with his last major scream roles
being in the TV shows Empire and Chicago
PD Michael larner died in April of 20123
at 81 years old sparking an outpouring
of love from folks across the
entertainment industry learner was
nominated for best supporting actor at
the 1992 Academy Awards for playing Jack
lipnick in Barton Frink additionally
learner played a significant role in the
2003 holiday movie Elf as Mr Greenway
the demanding boss of James Khan's
Walter hops however it was not until
2014 that he joined the Marvel Universe
in X-Men Days of Future Past learner
played US senator Brickman who votes to
suspend funding for Boliver tras
Sentinel program which would Target and
Destroy mutants sadly the role ended up
being one of learner's last he only
appeared in a handful of other films
after X-Men Days of Future Past like
Ashby in 2015 and the 2019 Netflix
mockumentary Frankenstein's monsters
monster
Frankenstein he may have been your
father boy but he wasn't your daddy
there are two Marvel Cinematic Universe
actors who appear in 2017's Guardians of
the Galaxy Volume 2 who aren't
professionals but they do have a strong
connection to the Marvel Universe their
names are Jim gun senior and Leota gun
and they're the father and mother of the
film's writer and director James gun as
well as kraglin actor and Rocket Raccoon
stand in Shan gun in the film The Two
appear as humans on Earth credited as
weird old man and weird old man's
mistress who watch earth almost be
followed by ego The Living Planet to
make things even more of a family affair
gun confirmed that some of the other
extras surrounding his parents in the
scene include his sister-in-law his
nieces and nephews and other members of
gun's extended family as he later
confirmed on social media my family
loves getting killed in my movies gun's
father died in 2019 making the themes of
fatherhood in Guardians of the Galaxy
Volume 2 it's even harder especially
considering that gun's senior physically
appears in the film gun's father has
paid tribute to in the credits of 2023
is Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3
alongside Marvel Studios crew member
Chris Reynolds and special effect
supervisor Chris Shaw Marvel has always
been and always will be a reflection of
the world right outside our window it's
difficult to think about the Marvel
Brand without thinking of Stan Lee the
writer behind such classic Marvel Comics
characters the Spider-Man and the
Fantastic Four together with artists
Jack Kirby and Steve ditco is
responsible for pioneering a new
approach to comic book characterization
ushering in an age of relatable
superheroes and real life consequences
most of the general public became
acquainted with Lee's presence in the
Marvel Universe thanks to his numerous
cameos in films based on his characters
over the years when the Marvel Cinematic
Universe officially began in 2008 with
Iron Man it had already become customary
for Lee to cameo in the films Lee died
in 2018 one year after his wife Joan who
had inspired characters like Gwen Stacy
and SU storm died following his death
many tributes were made to the creator
of the Marvel Universe Le's last two
postumus appearances in the MCU with the
2019 films Captain Marvel where Marvel
pays tribute to Lee Cameo and Kevin
Smith's Mor rats and Avengers endgame
featuring a digital ehh Lee in 1970s New
Jersey his impact on these characters is
still felt to this day can I return it
if it doesn't fit it always
fits
eventually William had a long and
illustrious career before joining the
Marvel Cinematic Universe prominently
appearing in films like Broadcast News A
History of Violence and kiss of the
Spider Woman the latter film garnered
him both an Oscar and a bafter award for
best actor hurt eventually made his MCU
debut in 2008's The Incredible Hulk
opposite Edward Norton as sadus
Thunderbolt Ross a US general who spends
a film hunting Down Bruce Banner after a
super soldier experiment goes wrong yeah
super
soldier
yes no simplification but yes Herra
Price's role as Russ usually in an
antagonistic role in later MCU films
like Captain America Civil War and
Avengers Infinity War meanwhile her was
diagnosed with terminal prostate cancer
in 2018 though he still made one final
appearance as Thunderbolt Ross in 2021s
Black Widow his final theatrical role in
general was an appearance in the King's
Daughter which was released in January
2022 despite being filmed in 2014 it
remained unreleased for 8 years due to a
dispute over its distribution the actor
died in 2022 due to complications from
his disease unlike Boseman however
Marvel decided to recast the role of
Thunderbolt Ross for future Marvel
Cinematic Universe films the legendary
Harrison Ford signed on to Phil herd
shoes in the upcoming fase 5 films
Captain America Brave New World and
Thunderbolts Lucy Gordon was an upand
Comer in Hollywood at the time she was
Cas in Sam Ry Spider-Man 3 as Jennifer
Dugan the news reporter covers Sandman
and Venom's attack on New York City and
subsequent battle against Spider-Man and
Harry Osborne before that she appeared
in a number of other films she had a
role alongside Heath Ledger in the Four
Feathers played Caroline Mitchell in the
2001 romantic comedy Serendipity and
even modeled for Covergirl in the late
1990s she died by suicide in 2009 before
the release of her final film gains bore
a heroic life in 2010 in which Gordon
port pra British celebrity Jane Burkin
the partner of the titular singer
songwriter Gordon was only a few days
short of her 29th birthday at the time
of her death if you or someone you know
is struggling or in crisis help is
available call or text 988 or chat 988
lifeline.org
[Music]